[Musique]
comme souleymane deux ans ils sont une
dizaine d'enfants ce mercredi 25 avril à
participer à l'atelier psychomotricité
une séance organisée par la ville de
plaisir à chaque vacances scolaires
depuis plus de six ans objectif stimuler
l'éveil au niveau de la motricité ça
leur permet de prendre conscience de
leur corps d'être en relation avec
d'autres enfants d'autres adultes
et puis de valoriser leurs compétences
par l'intermédiaire donc les adultes qui
sont présents pour stimuler ses petits
âgés de 6 mois à 3 ans un espace d'une
vingtaine de mètres carrés a été aménagé
avec des ballons des tapis d'éveil
déjouer un trampoline
les enfants peuvent également se cacher
dans des tunnels sous l'oeil attentif
des deux professionnels de la petite
enfance ou prise de risque est bien
maîtrisée bien évidemment il est hors de
question que les enfants se mettent en
danger mais on les laisse évoluer à leur
rythme c'est à dire que le concept est
aussi que les enfants prennent du
plaisir à être là à se retrouver entre
eux dans une ambiance tamisée la séance
s'est terminée par un temps de
relaxation pour ces tout petits entourés
par leurs assistantes maternelles un
moment d'échangé bien méritée après
trois quarts d'heure d'efforts